yeah some dude's trying to Grape you
then your man Jeremy comes out whoops
the [__] you wait wait wait that's the
word you choose a
[Music]
sensor so this is in Florida I mean
obviously I hate starting with that line
because it makes everything's so typical
Florida has some wild [__] all the time
so there's a dude that runs into a
GameStop and he just grabs up boxes of
uh Pokemon cards but not just any we're
talking Pokemon scarlet and violet uhoh
what does that mean Ultra PR good stuff
it's $120 a box W oh [__] yeah so he
Scoops him up he starts running for the
door but the GameStop cashier pulls a
gun out and shoots the dude before he
can get out at GameStop he's like not my
Pokemon deserved he killed him killed
him so the guy gets hit and then he runs
to the getaway truck and then he dies
like he doesn't make it w no that's not
worth that's not worth the what happened
to the guy that shot him did anything
happen yeah he got charged with a
manslaughter uh so then that would mean
like Heat of the Moment kill it's not
really like a it's not premeditated they
do an unboxing afterwards I wonder if
you got some this [__] that's true what
kind of kind of cards you got they did
an unboxing and a boxing oh God God
unboxing from jail does the driver get
to keep the cards though cuz yeah the
driver got to keep the cards sick trades
that he's done sent him to Logan Paul
higher value too a little bit of blood
on it history on it he he he end getting
I think he had to get like a 25k bail it
said for the manslaughter charge doesn't
feel like a lot shooting a guy no but
even in Texas you know how everyone has
guns I think that if you shoot someone
that has their back like not faced you
you're shooting through their back is
different charge yeah yeah yeah yeah so
for this I mean it's not standard they
do have standard ground law but not for
property theft so that's why there's no
way what's what's the standard ground
law cover if you have a threat on your
own life m wait if someone's just
stealing [__] from do they have the mug
shot of the shooter yeah wait that's
crazy somebody's stealing from your
GameStop that you're an
hourly with a with long greasy hair what
if it took like 3 months for that game
to get there you've been waiting for it
the whole time no it Pokémon cards oh
okay never mind what you been waiting
for for a long time all Gamestops are
like about to close any day now oh well
this is him I mean he's he's not dead no
this the guy that shot the dude they
call him the he doesn't have greasy hair
hey looks like he gets his eyebrows done
tooo he does he got like the he look
Latino like a Cuban man but that's a I I
find it so surprising that like somebody
would think he's riding for GameStop
crazy yeah why are you riding that hard
for gam probably save $1,000 why are you
riding that hard for it they can't
afford to lose any more profit remember
that Asian kid in Vegas that that that
was working at the smoke shop and then
those kids jumped over the oh he stabs
and he just starts [__] shanking them
and [__] he shanked them wait what
happening to the dude nothing he's a
hero nothing yeah I think they yeah cuz
there was two kids and they were they
were going to rob the place one of them
took the tip jar and then the other one
jumped over the counter he's like really
close to him so the dude just started he
just started stabbing him up with like
scissors or some sh no he had a knife it
was like a utility yeah but his he was
in danger though the guy that was
justified cuz he had no idea what could
happen to him but if they had just
that's hardcore though dude yeah be like
knife death I know it's [__] he was
doing he was stabbing him mult he he was
on the floor like stabbing him like and
that little boy was like I'm dead I'm
dead oh yeah that was a gruesome that's
what he said he was saying it like like
you're playing a game and like you're no
I'm dead already I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead D that scared nothing happened to
the guy that stabbed the kid because he
was protecting his life yeah but then he
was stabbing him even after the I think
I was like you got to make sure that
this guy's not going to whip out a gun
on the floor and shoot you I think it's
also the context of he gave them a
chance to go so they started taking the
money and he was like Hey can you just
leave the coins and just you can take it
you can take it and then they still kept
going so it was like and he started
swinging on him too yeah you had it out
so you know but in this case this is
like this is crazy this is cold blooded
just shooting someone on the back man
plus for the Pokemon card theft at a
GameStop of all things yeah like
GameStop does not care about you like
GameStop offered me like $12 for my PS2
and like [__] yeah [__]
[__] you know again resale for 250 bro
come on there's always there's always
those people out there that are just
like like I wish somebody would you know
what I mean like if he's already got a
gun with him at a GameStop he's just
probably that type of person I didn't
even think GameStop the place carried
like that you just can't test you can't
test anybody dog you just never know
some people just want to be tested yeah
you just never do do you guys feel
violated if you like someone steals from
you
I think your ego makes you feel like
you're violated dep depends on how
invasive it is IR feels from us if my if
I come back home and my room is rans
sacked drawers upside down that kind of
[__] like mattress on the floor what if
they neatly stole from you like they
took the thing out but they folded your
clothes and then like your laundry
they're just and then they only took
cash they didn't break anything and
their name is Gio oh that's why I always
keep my car door open cuz I'm like hey
it's open just go don't don't break
break my window oh yeah same thing with
my restaurant I used to you I used to
leave the cashier you know the little
the drawer open so I'm just like dude
like if you want you could see what's in
there there's only pennies and I take
all the cash interesting but I leave it
open because when you crush that thing
it's money for me oh yeah so oh I but
then they when they but I do have to pay
for the the door that was broken
Insurance what's a real question for you
in your home right let's say that uh
cuz we've had this conversation many
times about a robber like catching a
robber but let's say that you caught a
guy that was in the middle of robbing
your house like he's taking all your
[__] he sees you he has a gun in his
hand but he's like this you know for a
fact that if you shot him in this moment
you get away with it would you just take
the shot no I play put the up and down
if the gun's in his hand I'm not even
telling him to freeze yeah low key if
there's a gun in his hand I feel like
I'm just you can already see it in his
hand like but if he's poting like this
yeah yeah yeah he is like he sees me cuz
he's scared already based off body
language I'd like put the weapon down
and if he puts it down then but as soon
as I see him move any other direction
then I'm going to put at least like six
shots in what if but what if he [__]
drops it and then the gun goes and it
shoots you then I'm like what the [__]
did I just do can't believe you
entertained that thought that's such a
whack way to die oh my God misfire cuz
that's always a always think about that
I'm like if you know that it's hard to
to make millisecond decisions that's the
tough part yeah especially for [__]
killing somebody basically have you have
you guys ever been have you ever caught
anybody stealing your [__] in the middle
of it I would love to I would love to
like [__] no weapons but like I would
love to like find a guy stealing from me
and just beat the [__] out of him wait
wait stealing from you yeah like robbing
your house and you walk home or they're
like in the middle of ransack and your
car it's like I've been caught yeah I
got kidnapped how'd you get kidnapped
uh were you a kid no I was like 19 so
you're an adult nap yeah I uh we I was
doing a little deal I I was also Zan out
so I was in like thinking clearly I got
in the back seat and they drove off and
I had a gun to my temple it just robbed
me oh [__] I have been robbed in front
of me in front of you yeah it happened
like mid at the restaurant no no no no I
was working with a crackhead and what
you guys working on yeah a remix like a
like a group project no like I used to
work with crack KS because we were doing
this business where um they would bring
me stolen goods and then I'll give them
credit for um the boo to to gamble to
gamble no way waa so then so you're a
lone shark literally she was a thug so
so then so then they that's racketeering
can I say allegedly yeah yeah hold on I
don't know if you should say anymore
Esther as your lawyer maybe you should
anything about to catch a
RICO this is this show is for
entertainment this is a story like a
fake story I made up Tell me story but
yeah just for story sake allegedly um
yeah they were trying to so they brought
something uh and then we were going to
give them money for it or like credit
right but then they after we gave them
the credit they also took the item back
and just ran for some reason that's
still stealing they took the credit and
I'm just like why would you take the
credit you're it's only it's only valid
here so why are you stealing the credit
oh that is true
they're going to have to come back he's
like
suckers that is literally the most
unintelligent but but but he did get
beat up nice oh wow I love seeing people
getting beat up after they did something
wrong yeah Instant Karma that's F my boy
what our boy Jordan [__] um so he
lives in a nice Crib in Venice and
there's always crackheads trying to
break into his place and one time he's
on FaceTime with with with one of his
friends and he catches one mid- breaking
into his place and then his friend on
the FaceTime starts recording like
screen recording and you just see him in
the FaceTime just pull up and just all
you see is this and then the [__]
phone drops so you don't see it but then
he when by the time he picks it back up
the guy's on the floor like you got me
please and he's just beating the [__]
out of him like in the middle of
FaceTime yeah yeah yeah and then and
then I was watching the screen recording
I'm like holy [__] and I'm but it's like
it's like satisfying to watch cuz like
you piece of [__] you tried to really
[__] break into his house and you got
rocked so you deserve that but I had a
soft spot like honestly I feel like
that's the problem yes because I'm just
like I you know what like [__] what you
did but
it's we're not doing good business
either so who am I I allegedly who am I
was the nonprofit called crack for
craps that's a good
name cuz I like that when I see people
getting beat up like I get so sad that
like makes me very it is pretty sad when
someone's like not done getting beat up
and they're still getting beat up I
would I would I would probably beat him
up and then sit him on a couch and then
tell him to wait while I make a hot dog
for them and then feed them after
they'll probably have like three teeth
like but those are dop too right you
know those Hawaiian fights where they
where they slug each other out and then
they're just like hey good fight that's
dope to see that I love that that's
honorable I like scraps exactly but like
when I see fighting boxing kickboxing
whatever right and then I see them
getting beat up I'm just like [__] when
professional match but when I was
younger I used to find that so
entertaining but now that I'm older I'm
just like I feel so about I think about
it you know I have like fantasies in my
head I was like what if my what if my
husband was a was a boxer and he was
getting his ass be you know and he's
getting like all this like like blood on
his face I would is that an ick is that
an ick no it's not an ick I would feel
so I would be I would I would cry she's
getting turned off like ew you're
getting beat up yeah she's a boxer's
wife and she's just like honey
no why don't you dodge it what do you do
all that training for if you're going to
lose you're bad at this she imagines
she's like at the MGM with a fur coat
just like watching her [__] husband
boxer wearing a pink
wig way that's funny I I see anyone
getting beat up and it makes me sad
really even on your behalf even for you
like to defend you or your honors like
wait let's say let's say some gu is
being very disrespectful and creepy to
you and then that guy's getting beat the
[__] up by oh he like grabbed your ass
like in public or something yeah some
dude's trying to Grape you then your man
Jeremy comes out whoops a [__] you wait
wait wait wait that's the word you
choose a
sensor oh that's Jeremy why I'm all the
words you pick I'm trying to not get
demonetized yeah it's different yeah
yeah it's money involved it's different
this is a different code of conduct here
that's the
word it is jarring when you hear someone
censor something here if they were to
grab my ass and the person that saw that
like beat him up yeah let's say it's
Jeremy pink wig and all let's just
pink wig BL Turtle no I'd be like dude
honestly like I don't want I don't want
to see anyone get beat up to be honest
like like you grab my ass yeah like
whatever like let me slap you let me
like you know but spit on you whatever
you know I like that you say sorry
Naughty Boy you say sorry now you don't
do it again okay oh wow a very a guy a
guy that's going to grab your ass out of
nowhere is not going to let you slap him
and I will handle it myself dude I will
handle it myself but I don't want some
dudes need to beating though that's
true personally you guys can do whatever
you want and you guys you know but for
me like I don't want to see anybody get
beat up Just Close Your Eyes no she like
she's just hearing the noises please no
no I'm just going to be like I'm just
going to be like hey yo yo yo that's
enough that's that's what I'm going to
say I'll be like Esther go to the other
room while we handle business real quick
the noises might be even better than
seeing it that's why women are life
creators and guys are just destroyers
yeah destroyer of worlds so if you saw a
dude straight up grab a girl's butt and
her titty like this you're just like he
hey just stop that stop that it's so
weird it's so weird when it happens to
me it's different when it h than when it
happens to other people let's say let's
say your best friend just got groped in
a club then I'll punch him in the face
see the mama bear comes out I'll punch
him in the face and then that guy
punches you in the face have to then
I'll be like ow [__] no no and and like
obviously he's going to he's stronger
let's say he's he's stronger than you
obviously and then punches you in the
face really hard like he is not afraid
to fight you right now you you don't you
wouldn't want to see this guy gu get
beat the f I don't want I don't want to
beat him up to the point where he's
going to like get knocked out I just
want to beat him up to the point where
she's just like can't you can't win you
cannot win this one-on-one fight so you
want to see why can't I win let's just
be realistic kid let's just be realistic
but like you wouldn't want to see him
get stomped out by like your male
friends no like this is like wow that's
another level of empathy just the just
to the point where he's just like also
he's got a bunch of like kids that are
handcuffed in his car oh he's a child
he's a child trafficer yeah yeah yeah
he's on the sound of freedom and he
stole the Jade seal and he's going to
send it to Europe and he has the
Declaration of Independence I think I
think I'm only thinking about people
doing things to me like let's just say
they stole from me I don't want him
getting [__] up if they were to slap
slap my ass I don't want them to get
what about a broken nose and call it
call it even call it Square yeah what if
you just punch him in the face what
about that no I'll punch him in the face
but I'm not going to keep continue to be
you mean you mean you mean after he
surrendered stomping him out so once the
white flag is up it's it's good yeah
continue so like just one bullet is
okay all okay so then in the let's say
let's say you get your ass slapped at
the club right Jeremy comes in rocks him
in the face yes or no just once okay
cool and I'll be like but what if the
guy now coming back to punch but
Jeremy's a one hit wonder and it's
murder already the guy yeah the guy died
he died he died cuz you didn't know
Jeremy had it like that yeah wait he
died because of he removes he removes
his jaw from the punch he's wearing the
pink w Jeremy yeah yeah you didn't know
that he's all like power punches hey
Jeremy trains more time he say saitama
was it one punch punch Jer TR though
yeah there you go your own titty and
your own ass you're biting your lip all
of a
sudden hey would it be hot though if you
saw Jeremy knock a guy out in one punch
for to defend your honor I don't think
[__] like that is hot to me that's hot
to me and all the kids are free now I
would be so it you don't deserve so it's
like harder if if he sends a glitter
bomb to a hacker like that kind of
Revenge is hard you don't deserve them
you don't know how to bag a
[Music]
man